birthday wishes for an opposition inmate
outside his jail sergei tikanuski's
arrest
stopped him from running for president
so his wife stepped in
now she's in hiding but perhaps not for
long
svetlana didn't want to quit belarus
i hope and i'm sure that soon she will
return to belarus and that nothing
threatens her here now
the opposition to this man getting more
organized as protests grow
alexander lukashenko accusing them of
trying to seize power
but another presidential hopeful whose
wife also stood in for him
thinks the regime will cave nobody
believes him anymore
you know just because he would like only
to pacify
uh electorate to you know just to pacify
uh the demonstrators the people that
go out to streets and he's alive
how much longer has he got how much
longer will he stay on do you think
maybe a couple of weeks
maximum a couple of months external
pressure is mounting
too lithuania's parliament becoming the
first to vote to impose new sanctions on
the regime
eu leaders are due to discuss belarus on
wednesday
but they'll need to tread carefully as
russia's president putin
could try to use the west's response to
the crisis
to justify any action of his own
no sign of the rebellion fading despite
the risks
fury at the culture minister outside
this theatre
after its director was sacked for siding
with the protesters
we received a lot of wealth of support
from the cities abroad from our
neighbors from lithuania poland ukraine
russia and many many other countries
it's very important
because today all the artists
of our theater do say decide to be
together with me a real life drama
which has yet to be resolved debra
haynes sky news vilnius